lieber herr professor wiler sie haben
auch diese woche ihre meinung sehr
deutlich geäußert was großveranstaltung
angeht aber sie haben insgesamt auch den
blick über die entwicklung von corona
dem virus wenn wir sie bitten dürften
uns ein stück weit mit zu nehmen und uns
ihre meinung zu übermitteln ja sie wären
hätte ministerpräsident sicherte frau
kipping meine damen und herren zunächst
möchte ich mich herzlich bedanken für
die gelegenheit das zu tun und wenn sie
sagen hören ministerpräsident das ist
eine stunde der wahrheit dann freue ich
mich darüber sehr ich habe mich über
alle dinge die sie beide jetzt gesagt
haben ausdrücklich gefreut das möchte
ich sehr deutlich sagen denn
das gibt mir die hoffnung dass sie alle
den ernste lage wirklich erkannt haben
ich gebe eine präsentation frei
funktioniert das können sie die sehen ok
ich werde
einen vortrag halten ich denke eine
viertelstunde etwa vier schwerpunkte um
ihnen nochmals den ernst der lage
darzustellen aber auch warum diese lage
so vorhersehbar war deshalb habe ich
mich auch gefreut der ministerpräsident
dass sie sagen die länder im norden die
werden natürlich auch auf die wird das
auch zu kommen nicht kann nur hoffen
dass die dann noch rechtzeitig etwas
dagegen tun ragge national das sind
diese üblichen zahlen die kennen sie
wahrscheinlich alle unserer täglichen
lagebericht
ich möchte auf denen gar nicht im
einzelnen eingehen ich möchte nur offen
auf die linke zahl oben schauen
52 1826 meldungen sie sagten es die
gesundheitsämter sind natürlich jetzt
eigentlich überall völlig überfordert
die unter erfassung der wahren zahlen
verstärkt sich also hinter diesen 52.000
verbergen sich mindestens noch mal
doppelt oder dreimal so viele das müssen
wir auch im kopf haben aber was mir
wichtig ist wir haben in den letzten
wochen eine case für telit trade also
eine rate von meldungen zu verstorbenen
von etwa 0 8 prozent das heißt also von
diesen 52.000 dort werden und da ist
nichts mehr daran zu ändern 400 etwas
sterben ja in der bpk habe ich das ein
bisschen
zurückhaltender gesagt mindestens 200
aber wir hören 0,8 prozent haben dann
sind das ziemlich genau 400 menschen und
was mir wichtig ist das müssen alle die
jetzt zu hören ganz klar begreifen daran
gibt es nichts mehr zu ändern
wir können das nicht mehr ändern
diese menschen sind ja infiziert
davon gehen daneben 3000 auf krankenhaus
davon gehen ein paar hundert auf
intensiven davon sterben eben so und so
viele das können wir nicht weil niemand
von uns der hier sitzt kann diesen typ
noch 11
dieser
das ist ein eimer wasser der ist
ausgeschüttet dann kriegen sie nicht
mehr rein also alles was sie jetzt tun
und ich hoffe dass eben viel getan wird
das hilft dass zukünftig weniger da sind
aber die alle da sterben 400 von in den
nächsten wochen da kann keiner mehr was
ändern mit bester medizinischer
versorgung nicht das kind ist in den
brunnen gefallen also bitte haben sie
das immer im kopf da können wir nichts
voneinander wir können nur noch nach
vorne gucken dass wir hoffen dass alles
besser wird aber die sind alle nicht
mehr beherrschbar mit bester
medizinischer versorgung werden dort
mehrere hundert von sterben da kann kein
mensch der welt nur was dann ändern das
wichtig das sind die zahn
sachsen thüringen besonders hoch das ist
in unseren berichten drin das gucken sie
sich wahrscheinlich für iris land ja
auch jeden tag an das ist steigend das
ist exponentiell das ist schlimm alles
über r von 1 es ist schlimm wenn es
exponentiell ist
das ist noch mal eine ergänzung zur
karte die herr ministerpräsident zeigt
sind die altersgruppen und sie sehen
eben dass die altersgruppen etwas
unterschiedlich verteilt sind aber de
facto sind natürlich in all den ländern
wo die instanzen hoch sind auch die
jeweiligen altersgruppen hoch das muss
auch verstanden werden und wenn sie
jetzt mal auf die altersgruppen der
kindergruppen die inzidenz von den
kindern dann sehen sie dass da auch sehr
sehr hohe ins ident sind um links 0 19
jahre sehr sehr hohen tendenz nach unten
rechts plus 80 das sind ja die von
diesen +80 wenn die nicht geimpft sind
dann sterben davon 18 prozent da sind
aber gott sei dank viele geimpft aber
ebenfalls ja auch immer noch nicht das
sind sehr hohe zahlen ich möchte auch
nochmal ihm klarmachen wenn von über 60
jährigen drei millionen nicht geimpft
sind momentan drei millionen deutsche
über 60 wenn alleine die alle infiziert
wurden dann wären allein davon gehen
unsere intensivbetten schon alle belegt
wenn sie dann auch intensiv überhaupt
noch kommen
das ist eine grafik die ich sehr schätze
die mittel sehr schön die dynamik über
die letzten wochen und monate die
inzidenz nach fünf jahresscheiben und
sie sehen einfach mit der kalenderwoche
45 das ist alles rot und wird immer
dunkelrot und wenn du nach links schauen
dass letztes selber im letzten jahr im
letzten jahr war das alles nicht so
schlimm
im letzten jahr war alles nicht so
schlimm obwohl er kein mensch gelernt
geimpft war es sind eben immer noch zu
viele nicht geimpft 15 millionen
erwachsene nicht geimpft das ist zu viel
also impflücken schließen ist genau das
was uns auf dauer hilft und ich bin auch
bei volker beck wenn wir wieder das
zulassen dass ich so wenig impfen lassen
dann werden wir im nächsten winter eher
ein ähnliches problem haben denn mit
einem test kriegt man kein virus aus dem
land mit dem test klima das virus nicht
weg getestet das ist eine falsche
anderem
die todeszahlen nach sterbe woche nehmen
auch zu erwarteter weise da sind immer
vorzüge drin ich sagte gerade das
alleine von den 50.000 die wir gestern
gemeldet bekommen haben statistisch 400
sterben das ist eine 400 pro tag ist das
dann natürlich ein bisschen tage wo
immer die versterben von den 50.000
versterben also mindestens 400 wenn es
bei einer sterbequote von 0,8 bleibt ich
komme zum intensiv register die zahlen
sehen die teilweise ja auch sie sehen
rechts die neuaufnahmen pro tag das ist
schon dramatisch ja wir besprechen das
ja immer im krisenstab und wir waren
noch nie so beunruhigt wie jetzt denn
sie wissen ja auch dass leider im
gegensatz zum letzten jahr weniger
intensiv betten zur verfügung stehen
weil weniger personal zur verfügung
steht ich zeigt das kann ich noch sie
sehen also die verlegungen in orange
rechts und sie sehen die erste aufnahmen
in dunkelrot das geht wirklich rapide
nach oben und daher momentan zu wenig
getan wird und wer immer melde vorzüge
haben geht das natürlich so weiter wenn
wir gestern 50.000 neue
infektionsverlauf das können wir nicht
mehr zurückdrehen
das ist eine grafik die es auch ganz
interessant das sind die daten aus dem
intensiv register auf der linken seite
sehen sie den behandlungs belebung nach
schweregrad und ich würde hier nur auf
folgendes hinweisen sind von januar bis
november diesen jahres diese kurven sie
sehen die dunklen und einen dunkel mit
invasive beatmung und sie sehen die
etwas hellgrünen das sind die mit echo
also diese sogenannte künstliche lunge
und man sieht dass die alle massiv
steigen der diese zahlen und etwas das
hier auch nicht vergessen dürfen ist das
tatsächlich die patienten kurve
patienten länger auf den
intensivstationen liegen und dadurch die
kapazität natürlich noch enger wird und
was bei der diskussion immer wieder
vergessen wird wenn heute jemand ein
verkehrsunfall hat dann braucht er auch
intensiv bett und es ist in jeder region
deutschlands bereits in jeder jetzt wo
wir hier sprechen ist die normale
versorgung nicht mehr gesichert wie wir
das kennen es werden jetzt schon
schlaganfallpatienten teilweise über
anderthalb zwei stunden gesucht ob man
sie hinfahren kann weil die betten nicht
mehr freitags im frack patienten für
eine op s verschoben wenn kinder weil
wir auch fehler in der tat umwegs
infektion außer von kurve kam kinder
werden auch teilweise intensivstationen
über anderthalb stunden verlegt weil die
betten gesucht wenn allein die betten
suche für normale patienten außerhalb
von korea erschwert sich also die
versorgung ist bereits in allen
bundesländern nicht mehr der regel
entsprechend und da sehen sie rechts
ziel anzahl verstorben inzwischen sind
wir bei 80 verstorbene auf der
intensivstation jeden tag und die
mehrheit der menschen stirbt ja nicht
aus intensivstation sondern bereits auf
aussagen das hier ist noch etwas was uns
wahnsinnig beunruhigt und was uns
wirklich erschreckt das möchte ich auch
so deutlich sagen
sie sehen dass die einschränkung der
betten da ist das wissen sie alle gerade
durch die ärzte und ärztinnen unter
ihnen ich möchte jetzt einfach mal
meinen tiefsten dank aussprechen für ihr
durchhaltevermögen dieses land schuldet
ihm verdammt viel alle menschen die im
krankenhaus arbeiten natürlich auch
vielen vielen anderen aber ich möchte
das noch mal sagen was sie dort leisten
ist
übermenschlichen vor allen dingen wenn
man überlegt dass da so viele menschen
liegen die nicht geimpft sind und sie
behandeln die er mit der gleichen
sorgfalt und zuwendung wie auch alle
anderen das ist
hoch anerkennenswert
personal wird immer weniger das heißt
also die gründe warum ein bett nicht
mehr freigegeben werden kann ist in
erster linie das fehlende personal das
ist sehr wichtig zu verstehen natürlich
erkannten auch manchmal solche menschen
das ist ja auch selbstverständlich aber
ich wirklich wünschte dass all die
menschen die sich impfen lassen das
einfach verstehen würden wir dürfen
denen die sich nicht impfen lassen
wirklich nicht mehr die chance geben der
impfung zu entgehen zum beispiel dadurch
dass du dich frei testen können das ist
mal eine ganz klare ansicht und dass
hier das sind die prognosen wir haben
eine prognose tool für eltern im jahr
entwickelt zusammen mit kollegen und
kollegen in frachtgesellschaften die
sind ziemlich gut auf die nächsten zehn
tage diese prognosen wir haben das
kleeblatt modell wir haben das gefühl
dass das noch gar nicht so genau alle
krankenhäuser kennen wir werden uns noch
mal intensiver bespielen und muss gerade
letzte woche wieder drüber vereinige es
gibt offensichtlich krankenhäuser die
das noch nicht ganz umrissen haben da
müssen wir noch ein bisschen mehr infos
rausgeben
sie sehen die prognose sind super düster
die sind richtig düster wir halten die
im laufe von zehn tagen für ziemlich
belastbar die gehen alle steil nach oben
sie sind im kleber post aber das ist
völlig wurscht wir sehen die überall und
hier ist eine wichtige lehre wenn
patienten verlegt werden dann bitte so
früh wie möglich den patienten die
schwer krank sind und beatmet werden
müssen die zu verlegen ist natürlich ein
viel größerer aufwand sie wissen dass
bayern zum beispiel schon nach
süditalien
patienten verlegt teilweise ist es
natürlich auch gar nicht so einfach die
zu verlegen das ist logistisch extrem
anspruchsvoll er wird über medienrat
gesprochen über flugzeuge und das ist es
ist wirklich also es herrscht eine
notlage in unserem land wer das nicht
sieht der macht einen sehr großen fehler
ich möchte jetzt kontroll kowitz
vorstellen das tue ich einfach um ihnen
zu sagen dass das robert-koch-institut
wir haben in besonderen job das möchte
ich auch noch mal klar sagen es gibt
viele fachleute in unserem land aber wir
sind diejenigen die den gesetzlichen
auftrag haben die bundesregierung über
das bmg zu beraten
das heißt wir sind besonders gefordert
auf uns lastet natürlich auch ein
besonderer druck und ein besonderer
anspruch und auch meine mitarbeiter in
mitarbeiter wir sind natürlich alle
extrem ausgelaugt und gestresst aber wir
machen unseren job nach bestem wissen
und gewissen und wir haben im letzten
jahr eine empfehlung für ganz
deutschland ausgesprochen kontroll
projekt wir haben das mehrfache
bearbeitet und wir haben doch sehr klare
dinge gesagt und zwar allen auch
politischen entscheidungsträgern
insbesondere natürlich den
gesundheitsministern in den
gesundheitsministern konferenzen
ich fasse das kurz zusammen wir haben
gesagt je nach impfungen sind im juli
ist das entstanden also wir reden jetzt
von juli 2021 das ist glaube ich schon
wieder fünf monaten rief ihr monat je
nach impfquote in den nächsten monaten
in dieser altersgruppe erreicht wird ist
von einem mehr oder weniger starken
anstieg der anzahl der schweren fälle
und ids billigung durch saas kopf im
herbst auszugehen wir haben langsam
anstieg im oktober ihr fortan eine
beschleunigung des anstiegs wir haben
einen peak im januar und februar gefolgt
von einem absinken das ist unsere
aktuelle prognose die bitte ich sie
einfach zu wissen
ist unter der annahme dass ein
bestimmtes basis wo der geschieht dass
bestimmte maßnahmen eingehalten werden
das basismodell heißt wir sagt eine
bestimmte impfquote bei erwachsenen
voraus oder wir sagen wenn eine
bestimmte im bereich sucht dann wenn die
zahlen so und so sein und wir sagen dass
bei bestimmten impfquoten
bestimmte ets belegungen die folge sein
werden wenn bestimmte empfunden nicht
überschritten werden das haben wir klar
modelliert wir haben das publiziert im
juli diesen jahres
wir haben im juli das kontrollgerät
paper
ergänzt haben wir darauf hingewiesen das
war natürlich möglichst so empfunden
brauchen das ist ja nach wie vor so und
ich danke ihnen von köppen das ist noch
mal gesagt haben ich sag das mal ganz
klar ist muss jetzt schluss sein dass
irgendwer
irgendwelchen anderen berufsgruppen
aufgrund von irgendwelchen umständen
nicht gestattet zu impfen wir sind in
einer notlage und in einer notlage muss
man bestimmte dinge großzügig gestalten
darum bin ich hier ganz klar dafür dass
unter anderem apotheker impfen sollen
wir brauchen jeden und jede um jetzt zu
impfen die booster impfungen sind so
umfänglich wir haben viele millionen
menschen die impfungen brauchen je
schneller die geimpft werden besser und
die die noch nicht geimpft sind auch wir
brauchen jedes angebot jedes
niedrigschwellige angebot jeder mann und
maus die impfen kann soll gefälligst
impfen
sonst kriegen wir diese krise nicht in
den griff wir haben gesagt dass wir die
basismaßnahmen immer fahren müssen auch
stand halt mit jener alltag maske immer
das darf nirgendwo setting geben wo man
das nicht tut weil klar war mit den
geringen impfquote die wir haben können
wir die dort sonst gar nicht
kontrollieren und
wenn es nicht anders geht müssen eben
auch kontakt reduzieren die bevölkerung
bezogene maßnahmen seien zur altenpflege
auch nochmal an jeden der jetzt zuhört
es ist naiv zu glauben dass bei hohen
instanzen diese menschen geschützt
werden können das geht nicht
dieses virus ist so ansteckend der
sogenannte erwert ist so hoch von der
delta variante wenn sie die menschen weg
sperren wollen und kein kontakt zur
außenwelt mehr haben dann mag das
gelingen aber das ist natürlich aus
vielerlei gründen völlig inakzeptabel
aber wenn die instanzen zu hoch sind
wird es nicht gelingen das virus aus
pflegeheim und altenheim raus zeugen ich
bitte sie diese naiven gedanken zu
vergessen wir müssen die inzidenz denken
und wir müssen diese menschen schützen
so gut es geht und im september haben
wir das zuletzt noch mal aktualisiert
kontroll kurven ich bitte sie wirklich
dass alle zu lesen weil dort alles
drinsteht was gemacht werden muss wenn
wir keine wirtschaftsbezogenen maßnahme
greifen dann kann der verlauf der
vierten welle die bisherigen wellen im
hinblick auf die technik meldestelle
wahrscheinlich deutlich übertreffen das
haben wir im september gesagt
geschrieben in pressekonferenzen gesagt
ich fürchte welle kann nur dann deutlich
abgeflacht wenn man zeit hat die
impfquoten der 18 bis 59 jahren steigen
sagt dass deshalb
booster impfung sind wichtig das ist ja
gar keine frage die impf wirkung lässt
nach und natürlich gerade je älter man
ist desto früher also genauso prioritär
wieder impfen wie wir am anfang geben
aber nochmal diese 18 bis 59 jährigen
das ist die bewegliche population das
sind die mobilen leute sind die
arbeitnehmer die haben eine zu geringe
quote wenn wir die nicht unterkriegen
die ungeimpften quote
wieder vor einer welle stehen vor einer
welle die wieder unangenehme sollte also
das muss was getan werden und wir haben
auch gesagt das ist wirklich wichtig zu
verstehen auch wenn bereits großer
anteil besonders gefährdete person
übernehmen schutz verfügt reichen aber
dem sport nicht aus um eine erhebliche
belastung des gesundheitssystems in der
vierten wieder zu fangen also das war
alles bekannt in der 4 im september von
uns produziert gesagt und ich sage es
nochmal wir haben die pflicht
gesetzliche pflicht darauf hinzuweisen
ich bitte sie das eben auch den kollegen
und kollegen in anderen ländern die
vielleicht immer noch hoffen dass sie so
durchkommen das klar zu machen dass ist
kontroll co wird das kennen sie oder
auch nicht wenn es nicht kennen sie
können auf der website angucken ich wäre
wirklich dankbar wenn diese zahlen die
wir dort geschrieben haben als index
zahlen wirklich in deutschland genommen
würden und daran angepasst wurde
zumindest die maßen wir haben 15
settings genannt wir haben das
wissenschaftlich aufgearbeitet doch
stehen ganz klar konzepte für bestimmte
basisstufe ich wäre einfach glücklich
wenn unser land einheitlich und das ist
dann mein appell an den
ministerpräsidenten denn die sind ja
zuständig für die einheitlichkeit
einheitlich das konto wird einfach her
genommen würde dann kann man hier und da
was modifizieren ist mir auch wurscht
aber wenn sie wenn es den gemeinsamen
namen so dass die bürger unseres landes
auch vertrauen gewinnen in ein
nationales konzept das in nationale
empfehlung die stimme unserer website
zur modellierung zum schluss warum
wussten wir oder warum konnten wir so
fundierte aussagen machen wir haben
verschiedene modellierung durchgeführt
das haben wir im juli diesen jahres
publiziert und noch einmal angepasst an
die delta variante vor einigen wochen
wir haben bestimmte szenarien
modellierung sind natürlich nie
prognosen sondern sind szenarien wenn
dies oder jenes ist dann passiert das
oder den es mit einer bestimmten
wahrscheinlichkeit wir haben
verschiedene impfquoten modelliert
gerade bei den 12 bis 19 15 und bei den
über 60 jahren wir haben kontakte und
kontakt verhalten eingestellt was könnte
seinen vor und nach der pandemie nach
der es waren 50 5 kontakte pro person
und tag so vor der pandemie wir hatten
zwischendurch mal deutlich weniger nun
sind wir wieder bei derselben kontakt
stärke weil kontakt beschränkende
maßnahmen er nicht mehr stattfinden wir
haben bestimmte szenarien überprüft und
wir haben gesagt die kapazität der impf
ist 1,1 bis 1,5 millionen dosen pro tag
sie wissen dass das tatsächlich
funktioniert hat mal im sommer aber das
funktioniert momentan nicht aber da
müssen wir wieder und dann kommt da
folgendes raus also wir haben die basis
annahme haben die annahme dass
eine impfquote von 90 prozent bei
personen über 60 sind das haben wir
nicht wir haben momentan so knapp 85
prozent aber bei der annahme wäre das so
wenn du über 90 prozent wären und wenn
wir jeden tag durch die impfung können
das haben wir uns das heißt unter der
annahme positiv optimistisch war würden
wir bei den entsprechenden altersgruppen
wenn wir da solche empfunden haben bei
den unter zwölf irgendwann in zwölf
schüler bei den 12 bis 17 jährigen zu
weiter würden wir trotz einer impfquote
von 65 prozent immer noch incidents 400
gramm wir sind bei 65% wer aber immer
noch nicht viel mehr wir haben gerade
mal zwei drittel und sie sehen ab einer
impfquote von 75 von all diesen menschen
da tut sich was da sind wir noch lange
nicht das heißt also es war klar dass
wir mit der ebene über haben so hohe
instanzen haben werden wir haben eine
ets auslastung auch modelliert und wir
haben gesagt bei dem basisszenario sind
so und so viele personen in quarantäne
schuldigen in der auf der
intensivstation unter diesen annahmen
basis annahme 90 prozent der über 60
jährigen sind geimpft und sie sehen dass
auch da klar war dass sehr sehr hohe
zahlen auftreten können wenn nicht die
impfquoten deutlich höher sind als 75
prozent der gesamtbevölkerung also das
heißt diese analysen haben leider jetzt
ziemlich gut vorhergesagt was ist und
darum müssen wir die impfquoten eben
nicht nur die boostern nach oben bringen
sondern vor allem wir müssen diese
lücken schließen und dann müssen wir aus
meiner sicht dass theorien zum schluss
noch zwei folien ihnen folgendes zahlen
die sind ein beweis dafür dass die
kontakte reduktion eben nicht mehr da
ist wir haben zu viele kontakte der
beweis ist der das sind die sogenannten
akuten restauratorischen infektionen da
haben wir haben ja im haus viel mehr
systeme um die situation zu beschreiben
als nur die systeme die wir durch durch
gesetzliche meldungen haben sie sehen
diese rote grafik sie sehen dass es viel
mehr konsultation bei ärzten gibt wegen
atemwegsinfektionen als im gleichen
zeitraum des letzten jahres ist die
gelbe kurven das heißt also die menschen
treffen sich mir dadurch sitzt vielmehr
infektionskrankheiten wieder da und über
die belasten natürlich auch die
intensivstation gerade bei kindern
momentan das restauratorische
sozialbüros unter anderem wir wissen
nicht was die gruppe noch macht es kommt
ja alles obendrauf auf die intensiv
belegungen teilweise das heißt also dass
modelliert das genau ist aufgeregt
eingetroffen das wussten wir seit juli
20 21 wir haben zu schnell in vielen
bereichen geöffnet das entspricht nicht
dem kontroll co wird empfehlung des rk
ii darum müssen wir doch einfach wieder
gegensteuern das im innenraum mehr
passiert wissen wir seit langer zeit
barroso übertragung finden um einen
inneren hauptsächlich statt das wissen
wir das ist wichtig aus meiner sicht
klar gesagt dass wir sachen wie clubs
und bars die sind hot spots aus meiner
sicht müssen die geschlossen werden ganz
einfach habe ich keinerlei
da habe ich wirklich keine toleranz für
großveranstaltung hatte mich auch schon
zu geäußert ihr kontakt hatten der
behörden sind zu groß das kontakt
einschränkung wirken wissen wir seit der
ersten welle das hat hervorragend
geklappt die impfquote müssen höher wie
man das macht das ist eine diskussion
wert aber ich bin der ansicht wir
sollten wirklich mehr rücksicht nehmen
auf die verstehen die vielen
verantwortungsbewussten vernünftigen
menschen und russland ist wir können den
nicht geht nicht immer die chance geben
dass sie durch eine testung noch ganz
genau so ihre leben haben wie wie die
geimpften das ist mal eine ganz klare
ansicht die impf wirkung lässt nach
darum sind booster notwendig wir wussten
immer dass es so sein wird wir müssen
aber nicht wie lange es dauert wir
stehen jetzt etwa bei sechs monaten und
einfach meine meine bitte dass die
kontrolle die stiko empfehlungen
umsetzen und es gibt eine nationale test
die das robert-koch-institut auch
gemeinsam mit vielen stakeholdern
kontinuierlich erweitert hat da steht
vieles drin wenn sie sich danach richten
dann glaube ich es auch vielen geholfen
wir müssen nicht ständig etwas neues
erfinden alle diese konzepte und rezepte
sind vorhanden da gibt es bestimmt über
hier doch verbesserungsbedarf aber sie
sind da die sollte man nehmen wir laufen
momentan in eine ernste notlage wir
werden wirklich ein sehr schlimmes
weihnachtsfest haben wenn wir jetzt
nicht gegensteuern und das ist meine
einlassung danke ihnen dass sie mir die
gelegenheit geben das zu sagen das ist
klare sprache aber ich kann nach 21
monaten ist auch schlichtweg nicht mehr
ertragen das ist nicht vielleicht
erkannt wird was ich unter anderem sagen
wie auch viele andere kollegen gelegt
dankeschön